one of the things that I think people
have going back to this idea of like if
you start with the slow little stealing
of freedom it also happens with how
people are told about a bad situation so
first I was we're gonna shelter in place
for two weeks then it was let's add
another two weeks then it was you know
hey here's another week
now we're hearing Virginia DC a bunch of
these states are saying June 10th and
the reason why June 10th is so important
is if you go back let's call kind of
when people started to really take this
seriously middle of March you're now
talking about March to April April to
May made Jews three months 90 days where
those businesses are not gonna be turned
on even if they could on day 1 turn them
back on hire everyone back and start
paying them you're going 90 days there's
very very few people in this country who
can go 90 days with no income and be ok
man there's people that can't go a week
mm-hmm week like the majority of so I
got is blessed me and I'm yeah I'm not
gonna go into that but I right now and
as I'm trying to snot stay like in the
black I'm trying to like stay like out
the line and hire as many people as I
can because I had people even like in my
immediate circle that have been laid off
had been furloughed and they are they
were one week I mean it took five days
of no work for them to be like a min do
you have anything for me to do as like
we'll figure it out like yes let's yep
come on bro let's figure it out one week
now you're talking 90 days of no income
just that's a hard thing if you've never
been poor if you've never like lived
paycheck to paycheck
that's that's a hard thing to understand
where you get paid and you go and buy
like enough white bread the crappiest
peanut butter and whatever brand you
know from Kroger or Vaughn's or Costco
not Costco so they can't afford a
membership can they get the cheapest
that will last the longest and that
paid every single paycheck now you take
one paycheck immediately they don't have
any food immediately so now they would
go out on the street and ask for money
or they'd go and get a second job but
there's nobody driving and there's no
jobs to be found so not only do they
don't have any food but they have no
additional opportunity to try and to
make up for that deficit so now we're in
the slippery slope of you know 30
million people that are now immediately
stressed into poverty there's there's
there's not really bouncing back from
that when we look at the similarities
and the great depression numbers on how
long it took for us to come out of that
it's a frightening thing so when you are
having conversations and people are
having conversations about lives versus
the economy that's not what it is you
know it's really like it's lives versus
lives and freedom and you know I really
do want to highlight when you said like
it wasn't just a shelter in place
it was first trying to practice social
distancing and then it was okay try your
best to stay home non-essential
businesses stay closed
then it was shelter in place and then it
was in some places um you know church
congregations not only can you not
congregate and social distancing if you
do here are the new laws that you're
going to be violating and it's like I
have a lot of land let's just say I
wanted to on top of this hill put a big
microphone and say alright Church we can
meet in my field it's a beautiful day
I have exes and all the exes are
measured to be 6 feet distance from
everybody so you have to stand on your
ex we'll all worship together regardless
some Buddhist Hindu Muslim Christian
whatever that's took the point and like
we can't do that
think about that
like the government has said that we
cannot assemble we cannot assemble even
in the limitations and distance we
cannot assemble in metadata and the few
ways that were able to converse about
this is kind of through social media and
that in itself is a limited form of our
ability of free speech because everyone
in those different platforms to
communicate has its own agenda and each
of those limits what kind of
conversations can take place and who can
be who can participate most so really
like the First Amendment is gone in in a
month it took one month for us to be
like ah okay
we don't need that one anyways